samy naceri est aujourd'hui très y en
ayant un taxi pour la deuxième fois
c'est émouvant c'est gros j'étais bien
joufflu et où est-elle bruno qui fait le
casting et il m'avait dit là je le
saoulais je l'appelais tous les jours et
utiliser alors quand est-ce qu'on fait
le film away in j'attends je l'aï dit
écoute je vais faire le casting à l'anpe
et essaye de passer son personne te
voyais amène moi une photo cette
tactique je me suis faufilé j'ai rien
dit à personne qui rentrait dans le
bureau j'ai sorti une photo et c'est un
peu mon c'est lui qui fait le truc quoi
c'est génial de voir sa [ __ ] c'est
bien et voilà
image rose ça me fait plaisir pour toi
cette merci alors il ya un problème
quand même c'est que tout le monde se
dit enfin tout le monde vous disais il
faut changer votre nom parce que saïd ça
marchera jamais naceri ça va encore
parce que la série ça fait à peu corps
cité un lien enfin bon ça peut passer
mais ça y est ça passe pas et vos
parents vous disais c'est pas une
question de talent parce que bon mais
tant que tu auras un prénom arabe on ne
fera jouer les arabes alors vous avez
choisi ça me tient sûrement maintenant
de sa miss et plus c'est presque plus
qu'un prénom nom ouais mais il ya peu de
gens m'a même ma mère mes frères
aujourd'hui ma mère - parce que je
m'appelle encore saïd mais mes frères
mes amis les copains tout ça ils ont
pris l'habitude de m'appeler ça me met
surtout quoi quand au début ben les
journaux de merde là ils n'ont pas
dévoilé mon vrai prénom pour pour
m'assassiner
il n'y avait pas beaucoup de gens qui
savaient que je m'appelais c'est tout le
monde croyait que c'était ça me donc
même mes copains il faisait super gaffe
quand on arrivait du conte d'été dans
des feux d'un cinéma tout ça est allé
qui faisait les gâteries et donc ça a
joué le jeu et tout ça mais c'est vrai
que c'était difficile j'ai même pensé un
moment à m'appeler pierre morel ou cher
moral et je me suis dit
au jour d'aujourd'hui est ce que
j'aurais fait ce que la carrière que
voilà qu'arrive enfin les films que j'ai
faits comme raï comme petit ben comme
tout ça quoi
parce qu'on ne les aurait pas donné
alors vous avez changé aussi vous avez
vous avez peu fait attention à votre
langage vous dites plus comme ça je crie
ça c'est fini ça si vous êtes habillé un
peu plus j power way a annoncé le succès
donc vous trouver de la place au
restaurant vers votre mode chez disney
dimanche pas de soucis vous passez
devant tout le monde
voilà quoi il malgré tout malgré tout
quand même des fois vous pétez un peu
les prix il ya certains soient comme
vous j'ai le truc c'est que c'est sur
les deux derniers coups qui a eu
franchement ça valait pas ce à quoi j'ai
tout le monde qui n'a pas bu quatre
verres de whisky en boîte et puis s'est
retrouvé au volant il sentait qu'il
pouvait conduire le pire c'est que j'ai
changé le conducteur s'était pas moi la
voiture et vous êtes dénoncés en dix ans
ils make way je vais dire que c'est moi
qui conduisais comme ça mon pote et
laura rien et les matières brutes en nom
du coup ça mais bon j'étais gg j'avais
un petit coup moi aussi donc j'étais
encore avec certainement
et c'est même sûr parce que vous dites
quand même c'est que dans ces cas là
quand on se retrouve dans des plans à
peu quand on se fait serrer par les caf
comme on dit on devient vite un arabe
voire un bon résultat tout de suite tout
de suite ah ouais tu trouves tu en as vu
samy naceri là là là je les retrouve
avec les entraves aux pieds les mains
notamment dans la cage sans chaussettes
et puis quand tu es dans le carré compte
amène à l'hôpital pour voir si tu
arrivais pas malade tu as une bonne
ronde jette sur la gueule et puis on dit
sale [ __ ] dollars génial dites-le à
la télé ça mais je n'arrête pas de dire
j'ai dites le que quand vous êtes star
samy naceri tout le monde est sympa avec
vous mais dès que vous avez un petit
problème avec un chauffeur de taxi la
nuit et puis vous en payez un peu avec
des agents de police on vous traite de
nouveau comme un [ __ ] voilà c'est
vrai c'est ben voila moi je suis
habillée par la redoute mais je suis
tranquille dans les commissariats
le rôle qui est bien alors comme on
vient de le voir
samy naceri a eu des hauts et des bas
dans sa vie m'a lancé le on est ravi
pour lui alors c'est normal on va lui
faire une interview à peine down on ne
bouge pas